Hello and welcome to this new lesson on Java interfaces. The purpose of Java
interfaces is to let us unify common behavior. Let me give you an example of
what I mean with common behavior. Here, I have a sample program that draws a
delightful suburban scene with houses, and dogs and we'll add other suburban
items to the mix soon enough. Let's look at the code. We have a list of houses,
we add a couple of houses. We have a list of dogs, we add a few dogs. Then we
draw the houses and we draw the dogs. Now, we have to put the houses and the
dogs into separate ArrayLists because they're objects of different types. I
can't put a dog in an ArrayList of houses or a house into an ArrayList of dogs.
Our suburban scene would not be complete without cars, so go ahead and add a
few cars to our program. One for this house and the other two for the Mcmansion
over here.